Omri Kriegel, thank you
for being on my show.
How are you?
I'm good. Thank you very much.
Thank you for having me.
I am so honored to have you.
I've heard so much about you
from my good friend Mickey,
and you've invested in him.
And so, over the past, pretty long time,
I've been hearing about really,
a wonderful relationship
between an investor and a founder.
And I've been gaining inspiration
as to the type of investors
that I will look for
and the type of relationships
that I will want to have.
But Omri, I'd love to start this show.
Before we get to your investment thesis
and how you operate,
I'd love to talk a little bit about you.
Because you have an unconventional story
of your life journey.
And given all the adversities
that you've had, you've come
to a really wonderful place
with I think,
some pretty remarkable insights.
So, Omri, why don't you take me
all the way back and however much
you feel comfortable sharing,
I'd love to hear
about the different things
that happen along the way
and some of the insights
that you've gained from them.
Sure. So, again, thank you for having me.
And honored to be here.
Maybe I'll go a little bit
about my background
so just you have the full picture
about myself and where I'm coming from
and what's with my background and etc.
So, I was born in a tiny place
in the south of Israel,
actually in the desert called Arad.
This is where I was born and grew up.
I think it really was a wonderful place
that impacted me significantly,
mostly around values and morals.
And the people I grew up with
gave me the drive
and push to many of that
of, I guess, the values
that I'm currently aspiring for.
After a great childhood
down south in the desert,
I went to the Israeli army
and I served for, I guess,
around seven years
in the Israeli Navy SEALs.
So, that was
a very meaningful time for me.
I served there is a combat soldier.
Later as an officer, as a captain.
And I guess, this really shaped
my mentality around,
a never give up mentality, hard work
and things that comes with serving
in such a unit.
And then, I think that I went to do
my undergrad in IDC
which is the Interdisciplinary Center
in Herzliya and I studied
this administration entrepreneurship
in the Zell program.
And this gave me
some more understanding about business
and entrepreneurship in general.
Because I'm not coming
from this type of background at all.
Both of my parents worked down south
in the general works over there.
I had the best childhood,
but I don't have the business.
So, I didn't have the business
or entrepreneurial upbringing, sorry.
But Omri,
talk to me a little bit about Zell.
So Zell, I know very very well.
We had both Liat Aaronson on the show
who was the executive director,
I don't know if she was
the executive director
when you were in Zell,
but she a phenomenal person.
And so many other Israelis
that have been on this show,
Alon Halevy and Assaf Wand from Zell.
So, why go
to the Zell entrepreneurship program?
You're in combat in the IDF,
you grew up in Arad,
how do you end up deciding
that you want to be an entrepreneur?
So, you want to hear
the true story or just?
Of course.
So, I tell you the story.
The way it was, I was like every Israeli
after a military service,
I went to travel.
Some people go to the Far East,
I went to South America.
I already enrolled
to Tel Aviv University, to study the law.
And while I was in Bariloche
in the south of Argentina,
between one party to the other,
a friend of mine sent me an email saying,
"Hey, you was studying at the IDC?"
And he said, well,
"I think you would like this program."
"I think it fits you."
And I went to the website,
it was 2005, 2006
very different than what it is right now.
And I don't know, something ticked.
Something made me feel
that it's right for me.
The freedom around it and understanding
you're going to learn new things
and how to start your own business.
And I just said,
"This is for me."
And then I change my enrollment
and went to the IDC.
So, this was the thing
that made me go to study
in the Zell  program. Yeah.
So, how was your time
with the Zell program?
You starting out saying,
"Okay, I might be a law student."
You end up in an excellent
entrepreneurship world.
What are some things
that really excited you about it?
I think it's a combination
of the people around you.
And so, one is the people around you.
The second is the level of the program,
the level of the academic program
and the fact that
you can combine academic world
into real life hands on activities.
So, I think that this combination
was very unique for me.
The fact that I can learn and write
a business model on a business
that I'm trying to build myself,
which was a complete failure, by the way,
I think that it was
a great experience for me.
Incredible. Okay.
So, you're finished the IDC,
you finish this entrepreneurship program
and let'continue on the journey.
So, finished.
Then I I basically had an opportunity
to open a coffee shop in Israel.
So, I raised capital
for the first business that I did.
I raised capital,
significant amount of capital
for me back then
from external investors, from the US.
I brought a couple of local friends
that joined and invest on
as when we opened the coffee,
a big coffee shop in one of the biggest
entertainment centers in Israel,
in the cinema city in Rishon LeZion,
whoever knows it.
And I remember the night
that I signed the contract of this deal,
I didn't sleep for a whole night.
And I had a girlfriend back then asked me,
"Why didn't you sleep?"
"What's going on?"
"It's supposed to be a happy day."
I said,
"I can't believe I took responsibility
for other people's money."
"And if it's going to fail."
And a lot of, I won't say insecurities,
but things that are coming
with taking responsibility
and stepping up.
Right.
It sounds very healthy, by the way,
those feelings, right?
They are healthy.
I think that even now, today,
when I will talk later
about what I did today,
but even now, when I do investment
and manage fund which
with other people's money or founders,
they take money or take investments from,
it comes with a lot of responsibility.
And I think it's good
to have this sense of, I won't say fear
because fear is not healthy.
But sense of responsibility,
this is something
that I think is very important.
So, I did that.
I did it for six months.
I didn't even know how to do coffee
in the machine.
I don't even know until today
how to make coffee or anything like that.
I wasn't at all on the operational side.
After six months,
I've joined the UK based startup,
which they were looking for
an Israeli country manager.
Which was quite interesting
because it's a UK startup,
it's two founders,
and the first role
that they wanted to hire
is someone from Israel
to be the country manager.
So, in a way, I was first employee,
country manager,
part of a company that just started.
It was exciting, right?
I had a very great experience over there.
I worked with the two founders.
We're very close until today.
Great investor behind them.
And yeah, it was my first basically
international experience.
Starting to work
for an international company
and learning how to operate
in the big world.
And I think it was a great school for me.
And the company did well later on.
But I think it was
an exceptional experience.
During that time, when I was basically
starting the operations in Israel
and hired a team
and a lot of responsibility, again,
I had a very severe injury back then.
It was 2011
and I went to a party with friends
and I basically, I went with
a very good friend of mine,
girlfriend of mine for a night swim
after the party.
And I jumped in the bed
placed into shallow water,
and I basically broke my neck
and I was paralyzed for about, I guess,
I still am. I'm still injured.
And I have a lot.
I walk with crutches
and using sometimes wheelchair.
But I still suffer from the injury.
But I was in hospital
for about a year plus,
which was quite interesting.
Because I kept managing the company
from my bed in the hospital.
Really?
Yeah.
People came to do meetings
next to the bed.
And it was between rehabilitation,
to try to sleep,
to do other medical activities.
I try to kept my sanity
and to keep working.
It wasn't ideal, but I still try
to keep it a level of a routine in a way.
What was the hardest part
if you look back at that year and a half?
So, obviously,
there are so many difficulties
that come with such an injury,
whether it's the paralysis
of not being able
to go out of the hospital;
or not being able to be
as efficient as you want at work;
or maybe in the relationship
with your friend and your loved one;
so, when looking back,
what were some really difficult things
that you feel that,
I obviously won't be able
to really understand
through a conversation like this?
So, I think the biggest challenges were,
first of all, I felt.
I think that the biggest challenges
were to understand
that my life have changed completely
and to accept it.
To accept that was something
that wasn't easy.
Just imagine yourself.
Back then, I was 30 years old,
managing a company in a very young age,
dating beautiful girls,
doing a marathons, triathlons,
just super active physically,
and then suddenly completely paralyzed.
Neck down completely paralyzed
and then being fed, being washed,
taking me from the bed to the wheelchair
with a crane, it's losing
the whole sense of self, I guess,
or changing the sense of self in a way
was the most challenging thing, I guess.
In parallel to that, of course,
the feeling of disappointing my family;
and the worries about my future
and how it's going to look like;
and finding my friends
and everyone around me,
I think this was
a very big challenge back then.
And so, you finish a year and a half,
you come out of the hospital.
Obviously nine years later,
you're still dealing with the injury,
but you went back
to a lot of the original life
that you had before then.
And so, let's continue then from that.
I think that after I was one year plus
in hospital,
then another year in full rehabilitation,
but then I said to myself
I was very lucky
to have solid family around me,
great friends, and feeling that
I'm going to overcome it.
And I fought really hard to overcome it.
And I always dreamt about doing,
decided to do an MBA abroad.
So, I was from that young child
that grew up in the south
who then suddenly you're in the Herzliya,
which is the center of Israel
and Zell program, and then I saw success.
And I wanted always to study abroad.
And the first thing that I did
after I had my recovery
was to basically apply for an MBA abroad.
And I went to do an MBA
in Chicago Business School.
So, I did that 2014 to 2016.
It was a great experience.
Suddenly, I'm studying with
so many interesting people, global people.
Feeling that I'm being exposed
to new cultures,
new ways of making business.
So, I really really enjoy that period.
In parallel to that, I established
another Israeli entity
for a UK based company.
So, I did that
for about another two years.
Then I went to work abroad
in New York for a tech company
where I did business development
for the company after my MBA.
But I guess from 2014, '15,
I'm looking for investments
and I'm doing due diligence and sourcing,
screening Israeli early stage companies
for high net individuals,
family offices from abroad.
And we did a couple of investments.
And in 2018, I've established
a Homeward Ventures,
which is a fund that invests
in the early stages startups in Israel.
But not only, we've invested also
in American companies and others.
So, we're open. We're not necessarily
geographically focused.
And I really enjoy it.
This is what I do since 2018.
And it's a great experience.
And I learned a lot.
And I really really like it.
Amazing. Amazing.
So, I think it's just inspiring
that from an upbringing
that is not necessarily
the most entrepreneurial environment
that you have,
you come through the Israeli military;
you go to the IDC;
you go to the Zell program;
you study entrepreneurship
more professionally
through creating businesses
either failed or successful,
it doesn't really matter.
But you go to business school and now,
you're a renowned investor in Israel.
But I also want to understand a little bit
about some of the key takeaways
that you have from either
your upbringing, your military service,
the adversities that you've had.
And I know that there were more
than we spoke about here.
But they're very significant.
And I'm sure they are
a very significant part of your identity.
And I think this is
a very special episode for me,
because unlike a lot of other guests here,
it's a very special story that
a lot of people grow up
in a very entrepreneurial household,
or a very technological households
and they grow into this environment,
they don't put themselves there,
they're placed there.
And you inserted yourself
into a lot of these arenas,
whether it's business school
or it's the Zell program
or creating a business.
So, I'd love to hear
a little bit of reflection from you
about that upbringing and perhaps,
what you would tell your younger self
or what you would tell other young teens
around the world
who don't necessarily have
the opportunities presented to them
like you had?
Well, I think that you can find
entrepreneurial spirit work,
like step up mentality
in every culture where you come from.
I remember my grandmother
when I was young,
I think that this is something
that many old people in Israel
used to do.
But she used to buy cheese
that comes in plastic cups,
and after we finished those cream cheese,
she used to wash them
and she used to put a syrup in there
for drinking and stuff.
So, I think entrepreneurial
and thinking out of the box mentality
is something that you can observe
everywhere.
It relates to the environment
that you're at,
which Israeli is a very supportive
culture to that.
But it can come from your surroundings.
But a lot of it also should, I think,
or should is a hard word,
but I think can come
from your inner world and personality
to have a mentality or to feel that
everything is possible.
I really believe in that.
I really believe in dreaming big.
I really believe
that everything is possible.
Sky is the limit.
All these cliches,
they are not, in my opinion,
anyway, this is how my life
proved me so far.
I always dreamt about
being in the Israeli Navy SEAL,
but I was a chubby boy.
So, I did a diet at the age of 16
and I lost 15 kilos.
And I know I was strong
but I decided, so this is something
that I did back then,
or going into the Zell program,
which I had to improve some grades
or learning to walk again
with something that
I set myself a goal. I said,
"I'm going to learn to walk again."
"I'll be able to walk again."
"Maybe I can't walk as I used to walk,
but it's lucky
that we do this interview,"
what I said.
But still, I think that setting high goals
and having dream big and target high,
I think is someone that everyone can have.
And if you do so, I believe
that life will show you the way
and things can happen
even if you're not coming
from the most obvious upbringing possible.
I think that's amazing.
But at the end,
a lot of people face adversity,
a lot of people
are trying different things
and they're getting knocked down
and everybody says,
"Just get back up."
"Just do it again."
The knocking down that you had,
specifically, with that injury
and literally being paralyzed,
not being able to continue
doing the marathons and triathlons;
not being able to operate
as efficiently as you could
as you were in the peak of your years,
that's a dramatic knocking down.
What do you tell yourself at that point
when you're in the bed in the hospital
and you have people coming to you
for meetings and you must feel inside
that you're not fulfilling
your potential at that point?
I'm imagining that it's something
that is constantly with you.
So, how do you go through
that year plus,
what do you tell yourself in your mind?
And obviously that's something
that a lot of people
that are getting knocked down
could tell themselves, but for you,
it was a much more dramatic scenario.
I'll tell you a story.
I think maybe it will encapsulate
what my thinking around that.
A few nights after I was woke up,
I was in a coma for a few days
and then, later I woke up.
A few days after I woke up,
I couldn't move anything.
I was in bed completely
and I had a high fever.
And it was midnight or maybe one, 2 a.m.
I was sleeping in the bed
in the hospital in the intensive care,
and my mother was just next to me.
And I cried. I woke up and I cried.
And I didn't think that she will hear me.
And she asked me,
"Omri, what happened?"
And I told her,
"Well, Mom, I ruined my life."
"I ruined your life."
"I ruined my brother's life."
"I ruined everyone's life."
"Life is ruined."
And she told me,
"Well, as long as we are together
and you are here,
everything's going to be okay."
And from a mother perspective,
to think that okay,
she could have lost her son
a few hours ago
or a few days ago, or whatever,
and now he's here, then nothing is as bad.
So, I think that I always tried
and I still aspire to try,
obviously, I failed sometimes,
but I always try to grab or hold
into the positive and good things in life
and try to find the path around that.
Yeah, it was very easy for me
to be there and say,
"Okay, my life is ruined."
"I'm going to give up and that's it."
"And it's done."
But I decided to choose the other path.
To believe in myself,
to believe that despite the changes,
things will be OK.
And by the way, this is something
that I say to entrepreneurs many times.
Many times you can hit a wall
or you need to do changes in your plans
as entrepreneurs.
Business plan, your personal life,
whatever.
And I think that changes
are not always necessarily bad.
I can also see the good things
that happened since my injury.
And if you ask me today,
"If I throw you back ten years ago,
would you change?"
"Would you jump?"
I don't know.
I have a child today.
So many good things happened since.
So, I have work that I like.
I have a partner. And everything is,
So, I think that focusing on the positive
and on the good is the right thing to do
in any aspect, in any element in life.
Omri, this was inspiring.
Thank you.
And I'm very excited
to continue getting to know you better
and hopefully continue maintaining
this relationship, both friendship
and professionally,
because I just love your outlook.
And I grew up throughout high school,
with Dan Ariely as also a role model.
And I got a chance to work with him later.
He, too, he went through
some very very difficult adversity
at the age of 17.
He wanted to be a pilot in the Air Force.
He wanted to do different things.
Let's give Dan a brownie point here
because I know Dan well.
And after I had recovery done was
we had a lot of conversations
about injuries, etc.
And he really gave me a lot of support
and he backed a lot of my recovery.
That's wonderful.
And so, I get so much inspiration
from the two of you.
Right before we leave,
Omri, I want to thank you again
for being so generous with your time.
I know that you are traveling right now.
And so, thank you
for taking the time to do this.
But I need three words that you would use
to describe yourself.
And I'm going to throw in the first one.
Resilient is the first one.
You have two left, i'm sorry.
I never did this,
but I'm going to give you the first one.
I'm going to go on the phrase.
Well, better I'm going to go on a phrase
rather than words.
I think it's going to be, never give up.
Maybe that's never give up.
But if you want three words,
we can go with that as well
however you wish.
No no no.
Never give up is wonderful
Omri, toda raba.
Thank you very very much.
Thank you. Thank you for having me.
I look forward to continue
getting to know each other.
Thank you.
Same here. Thank you very much.
Bye bye.